[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo hombroselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos sobre la crisis
energética en la que está asumida la
Unión Europea desde hace meses Cuáles
son las causas que lo han provocado y
las medidas que han adoptado hasta ahora
son las adecuadas antes de pasar al
debate hacemos un breve repaso a lo
ocurrido durante este tiempo y las
medidas que se han tomado la Unión
Europea sufre una grave crisis
energética desde hace casi un año el gas
proveniente de Rusia y del que tanto ha
dependido el bloque durante años tiene
Los costos más altos de la historia
debido a la guerra en Ucrania los cortes
parciales o totales de suministro por
parte de Moscú y la alta demanda para
generar electricidad son parte de las
causas del incremento de los aportes
esta situación ha llevado a los países
europeos a pedir Con urgencia medidas
para reducir los negocios muchas
empresas han anunciado Cortes y algunas
naciones se han comprometido a disminuir
el consumo en un 10%. la presidenta de
la comisión europea Úrsula fonder
Legends prometió recientemente una
reforma del mercado energético hasta
ahora también se han dado más de 500 mil
millones de euros en ayudas a empresas y
ciudadanos por el momento varios países
piden un límite al precio del gas que
genera electricidad tal y como ya hacen
España y Portugal pero no es tan fácil
países como Alemania y Países Bajos
siempre se han mostrado reticentes
porque creen que podría aumentar la
demanda de un recurso escaso y que los
países exportadores podrían vender antes
a Asia y para abordar esta crisis
energética y poner un poco de contexto a
lo que está ocurriendo Contamos con los
eurodiputados Nicolás González Casares
del grupo socialdemócrata muchas gracias
buenas tardes qué tal bienvenido y con
Pilar del castillo del partido popular
europeo un placer estar aquí Igualmente
bienvenida
me gustaría empezar primero con Nicolás
y poner un poquito de contexto está tema
tan complejo Que es la crisis energética
la Unión Europea se ha pecado de ingenua
había países como España como Grecia que
estaban alertando de que los precios
estaban subiendo y que Rusia podía estar
manipulando los precios yo creo que ha
habido no más que ingenuidad creo que ha
habido Pues un poco inmovilismo y no
tener en cuenta que los precios podían
llegar tan arriba y suponer un gravísimo
problema para los ciudadanos y
ciudadanas países como España y otros
dieron esa alerta fueron los primeros
porque notaron también primeros precios
pero también aportaron soluciones y yo
creo que la comisión europea ha ido
lenta y arrastrando los pies y detrás de
los acontecimientos
Pilar estás de acuerdo en la misma línea
pero con otras con algunas matizaciones
yo creo que lo que se ha puesto en
evidencia con esta crisis energética a
propósito de la Guerra de Ucrania y no
solamente por esa razón porque ya venía
viendo unas tensiones en el mercado del
gas internacional
se ha puesto en evidencia como decía que
la Unión Europea es como un gigante
encadenado Tiene un gran actor global
con una presencia en
amplios sectores de la economía y de
manera muy competitiva por ejemplo
pensemos en la industria de manufacturas
pero sin una serie de recursos propios
que lo ha encadenado a terceros países y
ese encadenamiento se ha hecho muchas
veces a países que no son fiables como
está demostrando ahora mismo Rusia a
partir de ahí se ha puesto en evidencia
la desnudez que tiene la Unión Europea
en materia energética como política
común por eso hace falta ir hacia una
política
integrada en muchos aspectos donde las
interconexiones por ejemplo son
fundamentales y esto es lo que realmente
En fin estamos conociendo y viviendo
ahora la comisión también un poco hay
que olvidar que son los estados miembros
que deciden la comisión está planteando
muchas medidas que como en el consejo de
hoy por ejemplo se siguen estudiando y
no se toman decisiones conjuntas se han
tomado algunas pero quedan muchas por
tomar al final la responsabilidad última
está en los capacidades de decisión en
ese sentido conjuntamente todos juntos
de los estados que conforman la Unión
Europea
ha habido una serie de medidas hemos
tenido una Cumbre europea recientemente
en que Se abordó la posibilidad de poner
un límite flexible o un corredor a las
compras de gas natural y así evitar la
enorme volatilidad del mercado es una
medida que podría generar más consenso
Aunque hay países que también se oponen
cuál es tu opinión Nicolás mi opinión es
que también hay un momento estamos en un
momento en que los precios del gas Y por
consiguiente también los plazos de
Electricidad están cayendo mucho
derivado que hemos tomado algunas
medidas que han sido buenas como obligar
a que haya un cierto nivel de
almacenamiento de gas un 90% estamos
ahora y el otoño está siendo muy benigno
Y eso significa que hay menos consumo y
hace que los países los estados miembros
también sientan menos la presión de la
ciudadanía porque se esperan unas
semanas mejores Pero esto puede ser un
Espejismo y hay que actuar y yo creo que
una actuación clave es acoplar esos
precios de Electricidad de los precios
del gas porque ahora es cierto están
bajando han caído muchísimo pero aún
está muy por encima de los niveles de la
previos a la invasión de
Ucrania yo creo que eso hay que saberlo
y hay que avanzar avanzar sobre ellos no
volver a esperar que vuelvan a subir los
precios y se vuelvan a Elevar otra vez
el mercado mayorista a la electricidad
Yo creo que la comisión pero es
consciente que esto hay que reformarlo
algunos estados miembros también se está
planteando una reforma del mercado
eléctrico para el primer trimestre del
año que viene una reforma en profundidad
cuyo principal objetivo es ese el
desacople de los precios de Electricidad
de los precios del gas se han tomado
algunas medidas también y se pretende
avanzar más en renovables en
los permisos administrativos pero es
cierto que hay algunas medidas de
emergencia que cuesta tomar todo aquello
que tiene que ver con limitar los
precios del gas aunque solo sea para
producir electricidad como establecer
precios máximos o topes se encuentra con
grandes resistencias por parte algunos
estados miembros significadamente
Alemania y Holanda y creo que eso puede
jugar normal la pasada no solo a toda la
Unión Europea sino específicamente
Alemania que es unos estados miembros
que puede tener mayores problemas con el
gas quizás ya no este invierno Pero al
final cuando acabe este invierno habrá
que rellenar para el que viene y
volveremos a ver las mismas dinámicas
justamente está de limitar el precio del
gas y de la electricidad limitar el
precio del gas que genera electricidad
quiero decir es una medida muy
controvertida comentabas lo de la
oposición de Alemania y Países Bajos la
comisión europea De hecho también sigue
con dudas cuál está obteniendo la
realidad están controvertida es que los
países del Consejo estaban divididos no
en tienen visiones distintas Y eso se
produce porque cada país tiene de
entrada unos mix energéticos distintos
de entrada unos proveedores distintos Yo
decía al principio de mi intervención
que no se había desarrollado unos
elementos al menos básicos esenciales en
lo que debería de ser un mercado
integrado de la energía en Europa porque
es el final una fuente esencial para el
funcionamiento de todo y cuanto digo de
todo digo de todo no solo de la de la
industria no y al no existir esto y
por la falta de suministradores fiables
y un gran suministrador causante de la
situación de guerra que hay en Ucrania
Pues a la hora de abordar esas
soluciones conjuntas se pone de relieve
en las diferencias las distintas
necesidades por ejemplo Francia pues
Francia tiene en la energía nuclear un
suministrado fundamental a la hora de
poder activar su industria de poder
activar otras y de sectores hasta el
propio consumo de hogares etcétera no es
decir que el caso de Alemania pues
totalmente distinto porque Alemania
decidió que cerraba todas sus centrales
nucleares y su dependencia del garruso
es extraordinaria Y así va viendo muchas
situaciones distintas Y esto es lo que
dificulta por eso el no ver el que hay
que poner unos topes de precios al gas
en unos países y sí y en otros no pues
genera una serie de diferencias y hace
muy difícil esa decisión conjunta son en
estos temas en los que hay más
controversia y por tanto menos
decisiones en todo caso hay que tener
unas visiones flexibles y unas visiones
flexibles que no alteren el
funcionamiento interno del mercado que
no generen como consecuencias no
queridas Pues que se benefician por
ejemplo terceros países como
consecuencia de los precios más bajos
por los topes del gas y en cambio aquí
tengamos otra serie de dificultades es
decir por ejemplo esto de hacer ese
corredor de los precios del gas en
función de los picos de consumo etcétera
que sean los picos de consumo donde
pudiera haber un tope es una solución
flexible lo que es importante es que
sean soluciones que se apliquen en el
conjunto de la Unión Europea y que
tengan esta naturaleza flexible y en
base a toda esa realidad de diversidad y
que tenemos ir construyendo un verdadero
mercado integrado europeo de la energía
privamos
así los consumidores están sufriendo las
empresas están sufriendo Y a todo esto
tenéis la sensación quizás de que esta
esta falta de Mercado energético que
comentabas Pilar incluso todos los
problemas que está viendo para poder
encontrar una solución están
beneficiando de alguna forma hablar
pero no la ha conseguido y la venía
buscando desde antes de la invasión hay
pruebas y lo sabemos que ya está
reduciendo los envíos de gas O que los
depósitos en algunos países estaban a
normalmente bajos los que eran
pertenecían a gaspron antes de la
invasión esto ya lo sabemos pero yo creo
que ahí la Unión Europea ha respondido
unida otra cosa es que en estas
cuestiones haya diferencias como bien ha
dicho Pilar unos países tienen
diferentes intereses pero creo que se
Está avanzando en algo y es tomar
conciencia de que hay un problema común
de que las reglas del mercado eléctrico
no estaban bien diseñadas para estas
situaciones de crisis que no nos daban
la señal de que el precio las renovables
es mejor y ahora mismo Pues cuantas más
renovables entraban a veces pagábamos
incluso más tenemos que seguir por esa
senda de reforma pero también actuar con
la emergencia la emergencia supone
aliviar la carga a los ciudadanos Y eso
sí muy importante que los beneficios que
están teniendo extraordinario las
empresas donde de millones de bolsillos
de ciudadanos pasaba el dinero a pocos
bolsillos por culpa del grave aumento de
los precios y toda la crisis que
estábamos sufriendo que se aprovechen
unos cuantos Y eso creo que hay que
introducir medidas como nuevos impuestos
temporales a esa situación
extraordinaria y ahí hemos dado pasos
importantes la Península ibérica en
España pero también la Unión Europea y
me gusta que hay este consenso en una
medida que los sociasmócratas
decididamente Pues estamos a favor
Sí yo creo que hay medidas que se han
tomado conjuntamente se ha hecho por
ejemplo la primera es almacenamiento
decir realmente el almacenamiento a los
almacenes de gas están al 90% de su
total capacidad Incluso se da la
circunstancia que están llegando buques
metaneros buques con congas de el otro
lado del Atlántico y que realmente no
pueden descargar por ejemplo en el caso
español y otros porque no tienen ahora
mismo están llenos los almacenes de Gas
del almacenamiento de gas así que bueno
todo esto ha incidido en que
efectivamente se hagan esfuerzos de otro
tipo en relación a otra serie de medidas
Como por ejemplo los posibles impuestos
eso que se llama la de la contribución
solidaria que está en principio es una
medida a mi mother es una medida
acertada aceptable y Que bueno hay una
realidad como la que vimos ahora y esa
contribución es muy interesante muy
interesante pero que tiene que ir
directamente a las personas más
vulnerables y a meses que más lo
necesitan perfecto Lamentablemente nos
hemos quedado sin tiempo pero muchas
gracias por vuestras aportaciones a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de Europa hoy Gracias por ver
France 24 en español